[Musique]
bonsoir douglas y est professeur de
droit et spécialiste de sciences
politiques américaines bonsoir à vous
également taoufik jebali maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine
alors d'abord deux symbolique importante
sur la forme tout d'abord c'est bien
installée à un pupitre pris d'assaut on
s'en souvient le 6 janvier par les
militants pro trump que joe biden a
prononcé son discours
on le voit ici et puis joe biden il a
commencé également part salué une
première historique
aux etats unis la présence envoyait de
deux femmes assises derrière lui la
speaker de la chambre nancy pelosi et la
vice présidente
kamala harris le président américain et
la sens de la mise en scène et on
imagine ce n'est pas un hasard douglas
yates will
oui il a un bon bilan
il a réussi son pari avec les vaccins et
l'a promis sont mignonnes et les
dépasser 200 millions
et même quand cette personne la
population a reçu du mois un d'axa il y
a beaucoup plus à fait remis
symboliquement probablement c'est le
plus important parce que ça montre sa
capacité d'être efficace mais en plus
ces législations avec les les plans de
relance économique sont dits non
maintenant on fait des comparaisons de
joe biden avec flynn d'alan ball
secondes
je ne sais pas s'il est ce sont des
comparaisons juste mais quand même c'est
une bulle ondes positives les
perceptions de la première sans jeux
sont un succès c'est vrai tu as aussi
jebali c'était une promesse électorale
de joe biden la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire
du côté de la vaccination ça s'est
plutôt bien passé
et lors de son discours il a largement
repris ce bilan positif à son compte
est ce que c'est à juste titre tout même
pas ce qu'on peut imaginer aussi qui a
eu quand même une politique menée en
amont avant son arrivée à la maison
blanche
effectivement c'est difficile de porter
un jugement sur un action présidentielle
juste sur 100 jours mais c'est une
tradition américaine qui date des années
30 et la présidence de roosevelt donc il
y à une évaluation médiatique de
l'action présidentielle pour cent jours
et il y aura de l'année prochaine une
évaluation plutôt politique à savoir les
élections de mi mandat
maintenant est-ce que concernant cette
question de vaccination est ce qu'il a
réussi pas je pense qu'il avait réussi
son pari il faut savoir aussi que les
laboratoires américains avaient bien
fait de recherche depuis un certain
temps et que le terrain était propice
pour la présidence de brighton pour
plutôt prendre cette réussite à son
compte ce qui est tout à fait loyal je
trouve c'est poli politiquement bien
joué même si évidemment c'est une
question de chance
au moment où il prend la présidence les
laboratoires américains à savoir moderna
et enfin se trouve donc le vaccin donc
bien entendu je dois quand même dire que
la question dépend beaucoup des états et
non seulement de l'état fédéral
mais je dois avouer que l'état fédéral a
mis tous emplois surtout sur le plan
logistique pour faire réussir cette
opération est aujourd'hui plus de 200
millions d'américains sont vaccinés
c'est un exploit c'est un résultat tout
à fait intéressant je vais pas peut être
évoqué cette question à savoir que les
américains gardent le vaccin pour eux et
que d'autres pays à travers le monde
reste à l'écart de ce vaccin bon ça
c'est autre chose ça rentre dans une
vision globale de cette opération de
vaccination qui est compliqué à
comprendre mais je dois dire que sur le
plan vaccination je suis d'accord avec
mon collègue il y avait une réussite de
l'administration ou bayonne
alors il ya une parmi ses autres
promesses de campagne l'immigration les
violences policières l' usage des armes
quel est son bilan à ce niveau douglas y
est je sur les toits ce géo il est
défaillante donc avec les légendes
jaffeux en un puissant lobby des
manufactures des sommes qu'ils ont
acheté la majorité des députés des
sénateurs et donc jo byden été réduit à
mise en valeur son un ministère de tony
djalma le ministère de justice pour
annoncer un certain nombre de petites
réformes mais l'essentiel un grand loi
de protection des citoyens contre les
autres enfants était un échec
l'émigration aussi il à arrêter la
construction du mur avec le frontière du
mexique
il a renversé la politique de maslow
peine née avec les réfugiés il est rétro
pédaler jeu le sujet et la
régularisation des des migrants aux
états unis c'est pas clair il va tenir
ses promesses et les optiques son art
dans les états où les gens n'ont voté
pour lui pour précisément cette raison
et finalement avec les polices n'a
heureusement le président des états unis
n'a pas beaucoup de levier sur ce sujet
parce que les plupart des forces de
police sont sous le contrôle des états
et il a essayé d'appeler les familles de
donner des discours pour soulager les
tensions mais il n'a pas trouvé un moyen
dû changer fondamentalement le système
raciale donc ce sont trois sujets est
défaillante au louis tu as aussi des
délits on parlera nous d'ailleurs dans
plus tard dans cette émission
de notre correspondant aux états unis
justement de ces violences policières
contre la communauté les communautés
noires et hispaniques qui se poursuivent
taoufik jebali vous m'entendez non non
on a un petit souci de lison avec vous
en fait quel bilan vous faites justement
sur ces trois volets en les violences
policières à l'immigration usage des
armes oui pour les armes je pense que
c'est c'est compliqué et c'est perdu
d'avancé dans la constitution des états
unis
le deuxième amendement de la
constitution ça m'étonnerait que
l'administration brydon soit capable de
faire quelque chose là dessus sur
l'immigration c'est là où la marge de
manoeuvre de l'administration est un peu
plus grande
par contre même si elle est grandement
collègues a rappelé qu'une partie de
cette question doit être traitée par les
états par la police par les autorités
locales
donc quelque part c'est aussi très très
difficiles et il y avait l'art et de la
l'abrogation de la de cette interdiction
d'entrée aux états unis des musulmans
donnant le bain c'est déjà à son actif
il y avait une promesse
on va voir qu'est ce que ça donne comme
résultat de d'investir quelques
milliards de dollars en amérique latine
en particulier pour aider les gens sur
place pour qu'il ne fasse pas le trajet
le déplacement vers les états unis il
il y a quand même je rappelle il ya une
arrivée massive sur un frontière
mexicaine d'immigrés potentiel le mois
de mars étaient cent soixante douze
mille immigrés qui tentait de traverser
la frontière mexicaine mixte américano
mexicaine c'est pour vous dire que le
problème est extrêmement complexe
c'est un problème je ne vois pas qui
parmi les hommes politiques aujourd'hui
les partis politiques seraient capables
de résoudre ce problème il y a une
promesse quand même d'apporter une
solution à ces immigrés clandestins il
faut savoir il ya entre 11 millions et
12 millions d'immigrés clandestins aux
états unis qui attendent une
régularisation il ya une promesse de
régulariser en suivant quelques critères
communs de bien défini la régularisation
de ces cas là ce serait énormément
difficile moi je pense que sur les
migrations c'est un problème c'est une
question extrêmement epinal c'est une
question extrêmement dangereux sur le
plan politique
ça peut coûter cher au parti démocrate
s'il y a une régularisation massive s'il
ya une entrée masse massive des immigrés
sur la frontière mix américano mexicaine
donc c'est une question où
l'administration a pratiquement
trébucher il n'arrive pas à trouver une
solution
les centres d'accueil sont complètement
débordés et puis la police à la
frontière n'arrive pas à maîtriser la
situation
qui c'est pour vous dire que c'est une
question très difficile par rapport à la
question raciale
il y à une question qui aussi l'amérique
traite cette question depuis le preuve
depuis je dirais symboliquement 1619
c'est pas aujourd'hui que pareille de 9
à régler ce problème là il y a une
promesse de réformer la police et
surtout usage de la force de la police
c'est pas sûr
là c'est pour moi c'est des questions
qui n'auront pas de réponse sur c'est
sûr pendant le mandat
les élections de mi-mandat ça peut
expliquer aussi la lenteur sont ces
sujets là d'un joe biden la peur d'un
vote sanction
à mon avis c'est pourquoi on est là
aujourd'hui pour évaluer les 100 jours
et les 100 jours généralement si on
n'agit pas pendant 100 jours c'est que
on sait que plus tard il y aura pas
d'action
parce que généralement le président et
les élus
il a le soutien populaire il y a hélas
le soutien des institutions
généralement il faut agir tout de suite
l'ex le président américain il a aussi
un vaste une vaste ambition et là il
veut mener des réformes ambitieuses il
demande au congrès plus de 2000
milliards de dollars pour rénover les
infrastructures américaines répondre au
défi du changement climatique 1800
milliards pour aider les classes
moyennes et favoriser aussi l'accès à
l'éducation aux plus défavorisés
il veut faire payer la facture aux plus
riches mais est-ce qu'il a une réelle
marge de manoeuvre compte tenu de l'
incident majorité des démocrates au
sénat
non il a majorité de 1 seule voie et ça
comme son vice président c'est
précisément pourquoi il faut agir
rapidement et il est prête je crois à
sacrifier un certain nombre de promesses
pour accomplir cette énorme programme de
dans leur structure le dit notre
structure le problème c'est connaître
dans chaque membre de la majorité dans
le sénat tu as le pouvoir nous faire le
chantage pour ajouter aux réduire les
éléments qui ne lui conviennent
et il faut garder cette conquête ce
rassemblement des différentes tendances
dans le parti démocrate juste
suffisamment longtemps pour passer cette
législation
s'il arrive ce son programme de réussite
ici le chèque bon ça va ressembler màj
par exemple s'il n'a pas gagné les
sièges en georgie et si les démocrates
n'ont pas la majorité dans les cénacles
les premières 100 jours aurait été une
faillite complète avec terry progression
initiale
on a très peu de temps à parler de la
politique extérieure aussi c'est
important
quel bilan faire de sa politique
étrangère dans son viseur il ya la
russie la chine finalement joe biden il
donne un peu le sentiment d'être figés
dans une mentalité d'un autre temps
taoufik jebali qu'en pensez vous oui
pour la politique étrangère je trouve un
peu d'obama est un peu de tremplin dans
sa politique vis-à-vis il y à des pays
qui ont de la chance d'avoir plutôt un
regard bienveillant relativement
bienveillant de brandon de je pense à
dérange pense à cuba je crois que par
rapport à la question israélo
palestinienne
donc là de ce côté là on retrouve un
petit peu la politique d'obama une
politique plutôt ouverte et de l'autre
côté il ya un discours musclé qui nous
rappelle plus les discours sur le plan
rhétorique du mois nous rappelle les
discours de trempe à savoir un discours
extrêmement musclé vis-à-vis de la
russie vis-à-vis de la chine vis-à-vis
de la turquie et dans ce cas moi je
pense il ya une véritable inquiétude aux
états unis par rapport à aura un
possible rapprochement
le début d'un rapprochement entre la
russie rapprochement sur le plan
militaire sur le plan recherche sur le
plan économique entre la russie et la
chine
et ça c'est vraiment la hantise des
américains la hantise de l'état-major
aux états unis et brydon essaye de
répondre à cette inquiétude par un un
discours un petit peu belliqueux il faut
le dire
douglas et si vous êtes d'accord les
etats unis craignent elles
las cet éventuel potentiel blocus
hinault rossinot aux russes
oui le dossier russe est chaud parce
qu'un autre nouveau ministère des
affaires étrangères il est vraiment
experte cela rossi et donc il a des
ambitions de limiter l'expansion russe
dans le zone européenne
et d'ailleurs donc oui le dossier rousse
et chaude mais ce qui m'a surpris c'est
c'est que bailly aussi avec l'excellente
car d1 garder le cap sur la chine avec
des sanctions et les finitions avec les
lakers et il a gardé le cap aussi avec
iran donc il ya une sorte de status quo
maintenant et legacy 2 dans l'autre on
reste dans la plusieurs éléments de le
programme de la politique étrangère de
bayda merci beaucoup à vous et
s'agissant de l'iran on a pu temps d'en
parler mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
négociations en cours pour le retour des
états unis au sein de l'accord sur le
nucléaire signant en 2015 dans les états
unis se sont retirés en 2018 merci à
vous douglas light est un outil qui a
jebali